[Music]
dozen years ago the idea of having a
Cancer Genome Atlas was kind of
controversial not everybody believed
that we would learn that much about
cancer by looking at DNA because we knew
there would be a lot of misspellings of
DNA that we're not necessarily relevant
in figuring out which ones were was
going to be a big challenge to do this
well was going to require an enormous
amount of investment was sort of a dream
can we figure out how to do this can we
do this and we found out that we can
there's real value to go beyond what we
comfort to walk with go outside the box
don't just look under the lamppost
search through the genome one cancer
sequence might tell you something
thousands would tell you a lot more TCGA
was set up to take that idea and scale
it up and that's what has happened in a
pretty amazing way the goal of TCGA was
to characterize the molecular changes
that happen within cancer cells TCGA was
the first one to comprehensively map
these molecular alterations in a large
set of human samples for many different
kinds of cancers now 11,000 cancers 33
different cancer types all in the public
domain
for everybody to learn everything you
can about what causes this disease and
what we could do about
when we started the idea was that we
were going to find four five six genes
that will have alterations in the 40 50
60 percent range what happened was we
were finding a lot of genes mutated at a
very low level but then looking at them
in concert with their function we
rapidly understood that the important
part was not the genes themselves but
the pathways that pin out genes code for
proteins proteins don't work alone they
work together in complicated machines
called pathways or protein complexes so
one of the things we've been able to do
with TCGA is to bring those data
together across hundreds of patients
across all cancer types and really get a
better sense of what those pathways are
the large sample size and the genomic
throughput also allowed us to discover
far more cancer genes than what was
appreciated before the genes that are
frequently mutated in cancer and often
not unique to one cancer type but rather
across cancer types that's behind the
idea of a basket trial in which patients
are not enrolled based on their
histological cancer type but rather what
mutations that their tumors have are
using not just mutations but using the
gene expression data using the
methylation data we've been able to
develop a better sub-classifications of
individual cancers and see that in many
cases they might respond differently to
treatments the classification that was
put together by TCGA clearly indicated
that it was a subgroup of low-grade
gliomas that had a highly malignant
potential and they were treated as the
regular low-grade gliomas today the
patients are being treated and follow up
differently because they get classified
in the correct group that is a big
success there is not just being able to
classify patients into groups but we're
getting much greater insights into the
molecular mechanisms for those different
classifications those mechanistic
insights
you know further down the line lead us
to perhaps better treatments for those
individual patients some of these
discovery have led to new therapeutic
targets and even new drugs and
biomarkers new drugs that respond to or
or interact with or in other ways
influenced by the genetic variation and
molecular characterization TCGA set the
stage for all of that without it I'm not
sure where we'd be in precision medicine
for cancer today this was a team effort
of the most wonderful sort nobody
worried too much amongst the scientific
teams about who was gonna get the credit
so much of it involved teams at every
level teams and the genome
characterization centers teams and the
genome sequencing centers teams in the
analytics so team science reached a
whole new level with TCGA it serves as a
proof of concept that this kind of team
science setup could be hugely successful
and impactful for cancer research and it
has steered people's mindset towards
more open and sharing research
philosophy the group came together with
strong leadership and learn literally
learned how to be collaborative in a
effective way because we have an
objective and we have timeline to
deliver the data that the public is
waiting for
it's worth doing resource type projects
when I mean resource type projects are
projects that have not a very narrow
hypothesis but they go to create every
source of data that can be mined for
hypotheses and that's an important
output of TCGA I say serving is mission
of providing a resource that will
support basic research and drug
development and this rich repertoire of
data could be mined in many different
ways to address different questions that
each investigator is interested in and
he or she can then study it in more
depth and now after a talk I often hear
people ask a speaker what does the TCGA
data show for this particular gene that
you're interested in and for this cancer
type that you're studying it is only
logical that all the data created should
be given to the community at large and
when I say the community is not just the
scientific community but the patient
community patient advocates anybody and
I can interpret the data DCA has
followed that model in fact TCGA has
pioneered that model we were releasing
the data to the public way before the
papers were being sent for review this
model have supported the interrelated
and subsequent effort in epigenomics in
proteomics or those are very important
next step to enhance and enrich our
understanding of the genome it's just
been different creative ways that people
are now using the data it's publicly
available anyone with the interest and
expertise can go start looking at these
datasets and and and try to discover new
things
I try to remind people when the projects
started the cost of doing a whole genome
sequence was hundreds of thousands to
millions of dollars it now costs about a
thousand dollars is one of the reasons
that this has become possible and
frankly projects like TCGA because they
drove the technology to become cheaper
and they drove the analysis to become
more tractable or one of the reasons why
genomics is now being applied to lots of
other diseases too
what TCGA did because of the scale of
the project was to really push all the
technology developers out there to
really up their game how do we best do
variant coleen what are the different
standards you should use when doing RNA
sequencing in cancer etc etc and all of
that's going to have an impact in the
field and sort of pushing everybody
forward to a certain set of standards
that's gonna have a huge impact we have
that foundation of understanding which
we did not have ten years ago and which
will stand for many years to come
whereas an entire field the entire field
of cancer genomics the entire field of
genomics is in a different place now
than it was before the program with that
team working with patients and patient
advocates to see how all of that
information can be translated to
patients it's magic the data is just a
little part of the legacy the legacy is
a change in the mindset and the opening
of the door for other projects of this
kind I have to give a shout out to the
incredible dedication of the scientists
who made this possible and to the
patients from whose cancers these
tissues were derived everybody believed
in the vision that this could transform
our understanding of cancer they agreed
the data had to be generated with the
highest possible quality so that other
researchers could count on it being
right and they agreed to give the data
away so that everybody else could start
working with it right away as a noble
enterprise and so much credit to the
thousands who work to make this possible
[Music]
US Department of Health and Human
Services National Institutes of Health
National Cancer Institute cancer gov
1-800 for cancer produced January 2018